[Music]
[Music]
thank you tis the season for nonprofits
to mention the other parts of raising
money which those of you that are
members in the audience which is a lot
of you yes nice thank you you make up
about half of our general operating
budget and the other half comes in the
form of donations they comes between now
and the end of the year so those of you
that are able to make donations that is
what keeps everything moving it long now
and enable some of the amazing projects
as well as seminar series and so we
really thank you for that and thank you
for all your support over the last 20
years thank you DARPA is something I've
been reviewing admiring paying attention
to since 1972 when I first learned how
important what was called ARPA then was
to the development of computer
capabilities and to indeed the ARPANET
and to so much else and at that same
time that was when I was paying
attention to Buckminster Fuller who said
when you want to manage change in
civilization
trying to change human nature is a big
waste of time it doesn't change much but
a point of high leverage is tools in the
design of tools and the framing of the
design of tools and this is where DARP I
think has been especially valuable all
governments can do regulations
governments can do agreements
governments can do various things but
that the government would so adroitly
push ahead the most blue sky and
sophisticated approach to tool invention
and innovation has been at the core of a
pretty good society we've got going I
think and now that we're entering what
is being called a biological century
about tech century and genome editing is
becoming another form of programming
Dharma is right in the thick and the
person who was in the thick of that is
our speaker Knight
Renee orders in good evening thank you
everyone for having me I want to thank
Stuart in the long now foundation for
inviting me when Stuart asked me to give
a talk on engineered gene safety it was
a surprise I didn't really think about
coming to the West Coast to talk about
what we're doing back in DC about safety
but really through conversations with
Stuart I came to realize that we share
this enthusiasm for gene editing and how
this can really have an impact on all of
our lives across many different scales
from the scale of the laboratory bench
top maybe at a university like MIT where
they're sophisticated researchers
working together to a benchtop that
could be my kitchen or my garage these
tools are being democratized how do we
think of safety in those different types
of settings to whole ecosystems to
personalized medicine in an individual I
really started to feel this sense of
urgency that somebody needed to do
something about this and think about you
know hey who has the plan for developing
the tools that we can move forward
safely at the time that I started to
think about this I was an advisor to all
of the ARPA's to DARPA i ARPA which is
the intelligence community version of
the Defense events Projects Agency of
arpa-e since this is the energy
variation of DARPA and they all were
working on synthetic biology tools to
forward their individual missions and I
started to talk to the program managers
that I was working with like hey do you
think we can put a little bit of money
aside and think about safety in the
context of these projects and was told
that was a really good idea but we have
limited budgets we don't really need to
include that from the beginning so I
took it upon myself to go to the
director of DARPA and say hey look we're
pushing these technologies out there
into the world really and we're not
accompanying them with the safety
measures that
that should be in place and the director
at the time Aarthi pravakar said well
what are you gonna do about it so I laid
out a plan to establish a path forward
that I'll share with you today it's open
for feedback that's why I really like
talking about this project getting new
ideas of how we can see where our blind
spots are and try to fill those in um
you know I like the idea of the long now
foundation thinking about where the
direction of a technology may go and
part of my job is thinking where could
something possibly go wrong and and what
does this technology look like five
years from now ten years from now and
having done many of these types of of
activities even starting five six years
ago I'll tell you I completely missed
CRISPR cos nine that's really what
changed everything some of the the
projections it's almost embarrassing to
look back at at what we were saying what
biology would be doing today because
we're really achieving science fiction
level type of activities and I'll talk a
little bit about what those surprises
look like going forward and if you'll
just humor me for a moment I'd like to
tell you about the agency itself this
year is our 60th birthday and DARPA
itself was launched in response to a
launch this was the launch of Sputnik
one of launched by the Soviet Union in
late 1957 and this was really not only a
demonstration of incredible
technological prowess but also of
military dominance now here's a
satellite that went into orbit and is
now circling the earth and passing over
the United States several times a day
where the Soviet Union can have a look
on what's happening in the u.s.
President Eisenhower at the time put out
this memo shortly thereafter to say we
need to establish a agency the DARPA to
have the singular mission of creating
breakthrough technologies for national
security we can't let this happen again
we have to be the first and we have to
be the best moving forward to keep our
military dominance and so there's many
technologies that DARPA has developed
throughout the years this would be a
talk that could take days if we went
through them we heard about ceramics
earlier ceramic bearings but here's a
few other technology
that you may be familiar with so for the
Apollo missions DARPA was a critical
early investor in the technologies that
enabled the booster rockets to get to
space in the middle here we have the
ARPANET and this is a really a napkin
drawing of the four original nodes if
it's kind of blurry but if you if you
look you can see at the bottom circle is
UCLA which goes straight up to SR I and
last night at 10:30 p.m. was the 48th
anniversary of that first time that
signal traveled 350 miles so the first
Internet signal the program manager at
the time Licklider who brought this this
really this vision of this program
forward he also thought about things
like cloud computing and we're at an age
now where 140 characters reaches the
ends of the earth within seconds also
with national security implications
moving beyond that this is the picture
of the the car in the top right corner
is Stanley this is the the winner of the
urban challenge so precision guidance on
Tata misguidance and then finally really
the birth of some of the biological
technologies at DARPA our flagship
programs include revolutionising
prosthetics we're now closing the loop
where a man and machine can be
integrated together in this case
neuronal signals travel from the brain
to a hand to actuate a movement in this
case pick up a grape but also have
haptic sensation programmed inside that
prosthetic to sense how tight you're
squeezing that grapes you don't crush it
and that signal is relayed back to the
user really an incredible neuro
technologies we're trying to outpace
infectious disease and where I sit is
sort of at the interface between
outpacing infectious disease and
accelerating synthetic biology so the
diversity of the programs at any moment
at DARPA is really a reflection of the
program managers it's an interesting
organization where it's not top-down our
director doesn't tell us what projects
we should work on we come with our idea
to the director and say I want to be a
program manager because I believe in
this vision and I want to make it happen
we're there for only two to five years
it's a very short tenure
with the idea any one individual only
has so many good ideas and then we cycle
out and and new folks come in so if you
look at the DARPA website really the the
array of programs we have are from that
program management level and so how do
we make this happen with this incredible
sense of urgency we walk in the door we
really have a very basic way of how we
think about projects and this is useful
I think in and you know well beyond
DARPA I'm gonna use this after I leave
DARPA the hi-oh Mayer Catechism so how
am I used to be a director of DARPA and
he laid out if you can't answer these
eight questions and it's really not a
project worth pursuing its what are you
trying to do articulate it without any
jargon what's important here is that you
know for example the director of DARPA
he is a hypersonics expert he has no
idea what I'm talking about when we talk
about gene editing so I have to be able
to relay you know this is a critical
urgent issue for national security and
here's why we need to address it how is
it done today
how are we gonna change the state of the
art and who's going to care if we're
successful what difference will it make
what are the risks these are not only
technical risks we must address those
upfront but what are the ethical risks
what are the financial risks that will
address how much will it cost how long
will it take in the way that we relate
the urgency down to the folks that we
provide funds to is what are the midterm
and final exams to check for success
every project that we fund is we have
six months one-year two-year milestones
that must be met if they're not met then
we stop funding and we focus our
resources elsewhere to other teams that
may be making better progress I think
that's an important point to point out
DARPA does not have these fabulous shiny
labs we are an office building we are
people who's sitting behind a desk
delegating funds out to people we we
have a vision of what we want to make
happen and we look for the people to to
help us do that and it's my understand
there's actually several people that I
fund on programs here in the audience
today so I know you you feel some of
this urgency and pain and so really
through the answering of these eight
haislmaier criteria we seek to create
and prevent that technological surprise
so if we think of genetic engineering
and genome editing what what do the
seeds of surprise look like for people
working in the field of genetics these
will be familiar images to you
developing the tools to read and write
DNA so we gone from the low price of a
human genome for three billion dollars
which is the entire DARPA budget down to
about a thousand dollars in one day to
sequence a genome Illumina and others
are pursuing that hundred dollar genome
going forward the ability to write DNA
is also dramatically decreasing in price
and of course the tools to edit genomes
so we've had tools to edit genomes for
quite a while but CRISPR casts nine
gives us the ability to do so in a
programmable way really with just these
two components where you have an enzyme
that can combine to the DNA using a
guide sequence that says hey this is the
this is your cellular GPS it tells you
where you need to go inside the cell
make your cut here make your edit here
DARPA investment was critical under each
one of these technologies to bring these
forward and we are also critical in
bringing many of these out and
democratizing them by making the
hardware to make DNA synthesis and
sequencing and even editing out to the
masses here we have the Menai on
sequencer this is about the size of an
iPhone USB powered the DNA right this is
the digital to biological converter it's
not quite at a price point where you can
have it at home but certainly at your
research lab and the idea here is to
take genetic information from a computer
and have a biopolymer
printed out whether it's DNA RNA or
polypeptide really bringing this if it's
in the laboratory setting we're taking
it out of a centralized component where
we used to have some regulatory
oversight there is guidance for the
providers of double-stranded DNA that
they look at every order that's
presented and and you can look and say
mmmm actually this is Ebola sequence you
want to do that next level of checking
to see who's ordering this are they
allowed to be ordering this is there
something suspicious here there's
there's not formal regulation it's
really a guidance about 80% of the
double-stranded DNA providers adhere to
this guidance and say okay we'll be good
citizens we'll make sure that people are
ordering things that they should be and
if not the flagger for the FBI for for
further follow-up moving this technology
outside of that centralized setting I
think is empowering we can actually
bring innovation to more amateur users
or it could be things that we wouldn't
otherwise get from that maybe the
groupthink of a university setting but
of course this increases some national
security risks and these components and
then finally genome editing in this this
example here this is a kit that's
advertised on the internet actually I
think it's developed here in the Bay
Area where the audience's is really
focused on DIY community so
do-it-yourself biologists but there's
many sources that you can get CRISPR
cast 9 add gene and and and others so
these key enablers are really pushing
this technology out there I hope you're
starting to think about safety and why
why we might need that so it's just a
little bit of background on gene immedi
I think this is helpful for those that
that aren't really working on these
tools every day so this is a naturally
occurring system you would not believe
how many billions of copies of this are
in this room right now they're part of
our microbiomes and our microbes if you
imagine the market cap on this and how
much you're worth it's it's really kind
of fun to think about and do that math
but but the way these systems developer
it's it's a way for bacteria to have an
immune system so they don't have
antibodies and white blood cells to help
them defend against infection but what
they do have is is CRISPR caste system
so a virus here this is this little guy
in the top corner and sources DNA into
the bacterial to attack it and that
bacteria can cut up that viral DNA make
a copy of it and insert that almost in a
like a library into its own genome as a
memory of that infection so that it's
offspring the next time they're infected
with a virus it'll say ok I have a copy
of this virus I've seen it before I'm
going to cut it up and neutralize it so
this is this is a defense and what was
the big really innovation about five
years ago Jennifer down the song joong
and others recognized that instead of
using this viral DNA what you could do
is program
any piece of DNA that you want as a
guide to take this editor to a place
that you'd like to in the genome and
using editing parlance you could delete
a gene or you can copy/paste and insert
a new gene this is an incredibly
powerful technology so let's start to
think about what does the surprise look
like what's the sputnik of this type of
work so thinking of a bacterial system
what could be maybe program in Mass into
a bacteria enter George Church and of
course he has taken every single picture
in this moving image and mapped a genome
sequence to it uploaded that sequence in
the rapid upload time of about three
days into a bacteria and this is this is
on a loop it's a very short segment but
each and every one of those pixels has
been programmed into a DNA and that your
readout from that system is is
sequencing that bacteria so this is
starting to show you what these
technologies may enable one day is it
DNA data storage well the the price of
synthesis isn't yet at a price point
that this is realistic in the next year
or two but maybe in the next ten or
twenty years it is realistic there's a
window of opportunity here that we can
start to build in encryption systems
ways that we can start to to protect
this information if we want to as a
nation use these technologies beyond
that it turns out that CRISPR casts nine
is almost like a one-size-fits-all
editor so the rule is of about five
years ago was if you wanted to work with
a model organism you could work with
yeast and e.coli there's great genome
engineering tools but to use another
species you'd have to create an entirely
new toolkit this was going to be
millions of dollars of development and I
I don't think Christopher Cass is met an
organism yet that it can't edit so from
salamanders to pigs to rodents to
bacteria I'd love to at the in the QA of
sum of an organism let me know but but
so when you start to think about what we
can edit now we can think of editing
these things as systems as maybe entire
ecosystems may be creating new
ecosystems of the future or
reviving ecosystems from the past
learning from them there's folks in this
room that are interested in India
extinction bringing back things like the
woolly mammoth out of the context of
their original ecosystem maybe it makes
sense to not only bring back the woolly
mammoth but the plant life that that
woolly mammoth may have enjoyed
passenger pigeon Dino is also of
interest this second image here is of a
otherwise extinct plants an image from
the Harvard University herbarium so a
creative director at a metabolic
engineering company called ginkgo bio
works is looking at extinct species of
plants in Harvard's collection to see
are there new enzymes and pathways that
they can they can get from these extinct
organisms that they can bring into the
laboratory and start to generate
molecules that are of value and DARPA
has tremendous funding on the living
foundries program through companies like
zymogen and amorous and the MIT Broad
Institute to do just that we've given
them the task of generating 1,000 you
completely unique molecules that have
not been made by biology before as as
their their milestone and criteria going
forward so thinking about de-extinction
there is a time sometimes as a society
that we decide to eliminate something
from our environment smallpox is one
example of something that that we have
eliminated because of the incredible
suffering and death that brought two
individuals countries still maintain
stockpiles for for fear of resurgence
and you may have heard recently that
Canadian researchers actually
reconstituted an extinct pox virus in
this case it was a horse pox virus which
had also been eradicated as an
agricultural pest it had not been
detected anywhere in the wild since the
1980s and so as a society collectively
we have eradicated these species a virus
and the one individual or small group of
individuals has made the decision to
bring that pox virus back so I want to
emphasize that the power of small groups
of individuals here using these
technologies is ism
and it's important that we get the word
out thinking about you know I'm not sure
if somebody said in this context what
could possibly go wrong if we bring back
a horse Fox virus and you know it's
funny but it's not funny
you know how do we address this going
forward and I you know again emphasizing
thinking about the power of one genome
editors can be applied to even bias the
outcomes of inheritance and something
that's called a gene Drive what a gene
Drive does is it couples a trait of
interest with a genome editor in this
case if you want to suppress something
like a mosquito that's a carrier of
vector-borne diseases like malaria or
dengue you can couple the traits that
say that makes the mosquito resistant to
Tim malaria with CRISPR cos and so
through reproduction it makes a copy of
itself into the the sister chromosome
chromosome so we're mom and dad each
would have a different copy now dads
copy gets copied into mom's copy and and
there's there's a hundred percent
inheritance of your trait of interest so
for something like vector borne disease
you may want to use a tool like this and
people have heralded okay we now have
the technology to destroy all zika
mosquitoes or name your favorite vector
borne disease but at the same time we
have now created for the first time a
tool that can lead to extinction
so under what circumstances do we decide
to use this tool and understand you know
how this might work in the environment
and you know is there a way to do this
in in a measured way that we maybe can
do a local extinction and not a global
extinction these were some of the
questions that I brought to the
community to ask you know how can we
move forward safely in this world and
then finally of course human uses of
these technologies there's a lot of
people are afraid to use the c-word the
Cure word for cancers here but it really
looks like a application of these
technologies through some t-cell
therapies and otherwise can reverse
cancer even at very late stages industry
that makes transgenic organisms for
research tools use these same exact
reagents to cause disease and animals so
where we for those
that worked in an in a mouse house in
your graduate research you may remember
you know years sometimes of making a
transgenic Mouse to do your studies and
that's just when you can start to then
look at your drug of interest etc so
CRISPR Cassadine has made this a very
precise way to introduce mutations any
as new diseases emergence it's
relatively straightforward to put the
mouse and I don't think you need to be a
biosecurity experts who recognize that
there is a need for scrutiny when you
look at a tool that can both cure and
cause the disease and cause a disease
and enter industry if there's a human
therapeutics that are at play there's
going to be a number of companies
popping up to to make the most of that
technology I could name any number of
companies here's just a handful together
their market cap is is you know billions
of dollars and growing and what does
safety when we think about biotechnology
and becoming a part of the Bioeconomy
where does safety play a role here and
I'd like to just point out that many of
these companies were built on the
original prototypes of CRISPR cast nine
so the promise that okay we can make
these editors better and more precise so
when we talk about precision genome a
today I want to make it clear that these
tools all they do is CRISPR and the
guide RNA come to the DNA and they make
a cut and that is it they don't edit
anything they hand it over to the cell
at that point and the cell has DNA
repair processes called non-homologous
end joining or homology directed repair
and they make the edit so delete or
copy/paste and i think you can hardly
see it in this diagram but there's a
little green bar on one of the
chromosomes which is you're on target
edit and the red bars are off target
edits so these tools they're actually
precision DNA damage ours this is
another guide same tool where I think
you can start to see the red coming up
in this image where often your
off-target effect may outweigh your on
target effect so how do we make these
editors better so that we can start to
direct the outcomes of repair to get the
true edits that we want there was a
study published
using these tools that it was kind of a
very quickly published piece of work
that said hey if you use these tools in
mammalian systems they cause hundreds of
off-target effects in that one day that
this paper was published there was a
hundred seventy five million dollars
loss in market cats and these companies
very quickly the the companies and
academia came to say actually if you
look at the experimental design it's
probably overestimated the actual
numbers of off-target effects but but so
the the ability of an issue like safety
to move a market like this if if the
existential concern doesn't get you then
maybe maybe the financial one will so
and then people are taking us into their
own hands folks that can't wait for the
long timelines of an FDA approval maybe
you have an inherited genetic disease
and and your clock is ticking
what can you do and this is really I
think a nice image from MIT technology
review about an individual in this case
who really well-educated looked and he
didn't have a disease per se but he
wanted to look at a way to increase his
stamina and in longevity so he looked at
the sequence for human growth hormone
releasing hormone he ordered a plasmid
that's what this circular piece of DNA
is that encoded this protein this gene
it was delivered to him he found a
doctor who injected him first they did a
tattoo so you can see where he injected
it so if a thing went wrong you'd know
where to cut out and and he injected
himself there but what's important to
know is that when you inject yourself
with circular DNA it doesn't just get
taken up in the cells you actually have
to apply an electrical current to make
sure that it gets in so this doctor also
applied an electrical shock to make sure
that this was taken up and I guess he's
fine I don't know what's uh what's
happening but but I think that the real
emphasis is is this is this is one story
of many that are starting to accumulate
that people are taking this into their
their own hands of theory if they can't
wait for a therapy they're going to try
to make these therapy themselves
this individual argues that you know
this is not this does not pose any any
harm to the public so it
it's fine to do but I guess if I had the
opportunity to talk to that individual
I'd ask well you know have you talked to
your insurance company about this if
something bad should happen what does
this do to the industry as a whole we're
trying to develop beneficent genome
editing technologies and if something
goes wrong what if it's misinterpreted
as as this this field being a problem
and of course we know the case with AAV
therapies where we sleep for a very long
time stop doing gene therapies because
of an adverse event and we thought that
genome editing was on the horizon it's
already here researchers in the US and
globally are editing in the germline so
the Washington Post's I think sums this
up really well saying new genome editing
tools could cure disease or customize
kids or aid bioterrorism you pick and
what I'm looking at at DARPA is thinking
about okay I'm starting to get really
worried about bio error so this would be
somebody a well intending individual
maybe the gentleman that's that's doing
self DIY therapies causing an event that
we had not anticipated how do we
mitigate that risk
what about releasing a mosquito a gene
drive mosquito environment creates a new
ecological niche that gets filled by an
even more deadly virus carrying insect
how do we mitigate that risk of bio
error and then I'll be checking the box
for national security and while I
developed the tools to protect against
bio error will be will be that same
toolkit can be applied really to
bioterror they they they end with the
same result there's some lessons that I
think we can learn going back to see the
ARPANET and the 40th anniversary no
criticism of the folks that that brought
the Internet to us but if if they had
the opportunity to look back and say
could we have developed security of
those systems from the onset we wouldn't
be worried about maybe cyber security as
much as we are now there's entire floors
that DARPA dedicated to this the NSA is
dedicated to this would we be in a
better position if we had built-in
safety from the beginning
so with this in mind I went to the
community and I said if we want to use
genome editing technologies what are
ways that we can control these editors
counter them if they should go rogue and
if they should introduce an edit into an
environment or an organism that we
didn't want to be there how could we
mediate that change and bring it back to
baseline and so that formed the basis
for a program that I call safe teens and
the call went to proposers to to address
just these things the first the control
of genome editing this is turning an
editor on where you want them when you
want them and once they're done doing
their job converting its substrate
remove them from the system it's when
they hang around in cells after they've
turned over their substrate that they
start to accumulate those off-target
effects if we're going into the clinic
with a gene editor we don't have any
antidote we don't have any way to shut
those systems down if you think about
taking a medicine that you may have a
side effect from if there is a side
effect you can stop taking that medicine
your body metabolizes it and you'll go
back to baseline if something is
permanently changing your genome and
something goes wrong you really want to
have something at the ready with you to
to be able to shut down that editor to
halt further further damage and if there
is any damage inferred then we can also
try to remediate that damage and the
teams that we funded we picked seven
teams I'll go into the the teams that
answer the call to this but just to give
you a flavor of the the different types
of efforts that we're funding we're
about six months in and we have folks
looking at controllable genome editors
this is having a genome editor work only
when you add a small molecule of
interest we have generation counters so
they're not quite at the level of a
thousand or 10,000 year clock but they
can count that they've gone through five
generations stop the gene drive ten
generations stop the gene drive so these
are these are smart systems if we build
these autonomous systems that we
released into the wild we want to build
in fail-safes for our cars that are
autonomous let's build them for our gene
drives that are also trying to be
autonomous for countermeasures and
prophylaxis we have a broad swath of
technologies we're funding now from
nucleic acids to small molecule
inhibitors to protein inhibitor
interestingly most of these protein
inhibitors comes from the phage
themselves that were initially trying to
infect those bacteria of course they've
evolved resistances so nature is going
to combat and counter these gene editors
and then finally genetic remediation
this is an area that I would I would
love to solicit new ideas in so it's
it's very difficult to keep pace with
something like a gene Drive so something
that biases inheritance to a hundred
percent I can't tell you how many ideas
that we got from individuals that says
that said ok if you release a gene Drive
let's create a reversal Drive to reverse
that same gene Drive well from a
regulatory perspective talking with the
FDA they kind of scratched their heads
and said ok so you send out the first
gene drive and it breaks and then you
want me to let you release the second
one to fix it so of course that won't
work in the long run so I think this is
one area that we really need to think
about how can we develop technologies to
keep pace with remediation and gene
drives and then finally much of this
work to date really has just been
computer models what could happen if we
release the gene drive what could happen
if we use this therapeutically and we're
starting to actually do this testing in
laboratory systems over many generations
to see what are the what are the impacts
of evolution what is the stability of
these systems to walk you through one
example for vector control the state of
the art so now I'm going to the hi all
Myer criteria you can see the current
state of the art here is environmental
modification this is you know removing
the habitat for mosquitoes to live in
it's spraying with insecticides and more
recently it's sterile insect techniques
so you could array d8m mosquito to make
it sterile these mosquitoes tend not to
be very fit so or you could genetically
engineer a mosquito to be sterile groups
like oxy tech are are releasing
mosquitoes this not a gene drive but
it's a it's a sterile insect that when
released it survives for about two weeks
and is sterile so there's there's no
offspring the paradigm shift here is the
gene drive of course so this would
theoretically be a way to to release one
or a few organisms to suppress entire
populations
if we decide to use a tool like this
that could eliminate mosquitoes that
carry disease but also potentially make
that species extinct let's think about
what development of safe teens tools
would do if to engineer the mosquito
drive this forward with the tools
afforded by safe genes we can build in
that control keep it local we can help
the spread of an unwanted gene drive if
it gets beyond a geographic area that
we'd like to confine it to and we can
also restore a system back to baseline
making the smallest change possible we
don't want to have to follow back in
with pesticides or something like this
let's let's restore that system back
these are the teams that were funding we
have really a broad swath of academic
researchers mostly looking first at
high-throughput models that give it very
short timelines for a DARPA program
safety and oil is only a four-year
program so there's only a very limited
number of generations that we can have
for something like a gene drive so to
look at a greater number of generations
we're including high throughput models
so these are fly flies yeast and worms
and really using these really awesome
liquid handling robots that allow
continuous evolution of these systems to
look at the different drive constructs
to see which ones are the most robust
over multiple generations which ones do
we have the best control over and what
are the components that evolution that
really worked to to create resistances
in these systems we have four mosquito
vectors that we're looking at that carry
any number of diseases and then finally
if we're successful we'll create the
first mammalian based gene Drive in
rodents these rodents are invasive
species and many islands type of
environments but they also carry some
diseases like Lyme and plague and this
this last point I'd really if people are
kind of scratching their heads like why
does the DoD care about invasive species
and it's you know biodiversity of any
given environment actually protects the
organisms in that environment from
disease having that incredible
biodiversity is really helpful on the
national security perspective because
less disease means more stable nations
let's here's just another
tool in the toolbox that we can start to
look at there's multiple design drives
gene drive designs we can think about
threshold independent this means small
release large impact or threshold
dependent this would be where you have
to release many many species to to reach
a given threshold what these designs
afford is if it winds sweeps in and
brings your mosquito to the next valley
that it won't reinitiate a gene drive
there it would it would keep it local
and then on the therapeutic side there's
two projects that we funded one is from
George church's lab and he has a very
ambitious goal of trying to reverse
damage induced by ionizing radiation so
if you think about it from the national
security perspective the we are often
first responders to a rady radiation
event you're of course familiar with
with fukushima in those cases they they
sent in robots early on because they
couldn't send individuals and because of
the damage that would be caused to those
individuals how can we find the cells
that have been damaged with the ionizing
radiation and and restore them back to a
baseline state from the DNA from the
reagent delivery perspective this is
very difficult I have 32 trillion cells
how will this team get to each of those
cells that's that's been damaged and so
we'll see how George does for the and
for the Jennifer down and we funded her
to look at a really exciting application
of RNA editors so I've mostly talked
about DNA editors today but this is
looking at a virus it could be an
engineered virus it could be a naturally
occurring virus in her case she's
looking at Zika and Ebola and if we
think about our current countermeasures
against these types of viruses the
traditional targets are surface protein
so our immune system sees the surface
proteins on a virus and makes an
antibody against it and we can clear
that out from our system if you can have
access to that entire genome you can
start to look at sequences that are
conserved across many different strains
of viruses for the first time getting
close to a universal neutralizing
reagent and that's really what Jennifer
is trying to do we talked about the
digital to biological
murder earlier this is a way that you
can start with only digital sequence of
DNA that you know from a virus and
create a countermeasure against it then
finally thinking about in the next four
years of safe genes we're going to be
addressing some of these hard technical
goals these are the the quantifiable
this is the data that leads to
publications that leads to new
technologies and new companies control
of all gene editors how they precise
genome editing inhibitors of genome
editing and gene drives that we can
maybe one day field and then also the
soft questions so what I've done this
program is made sure that we've set
aside some funds for each team to have
interactions with the regulatory bodies
with the community with bioethicists to
ask you know what level of safety is
acceptable how do we appropriately
monitor gene editing and and who does
the decision-making in these types of
technologies in a way I'm also providing
some soft governance here there are no
rules to the funding of gene drives so
in my call for proposals I made up rules
and I said ok you have to have at least
this stringent level of safety before
we'll even consider you for a proposal
and this was done with with conferring
with with many different experts with
the people that wrote the guidance on
arthropod containment you know what what
is this is this is this a bsl-3 level
but if we decide that it's safe and do
we just go from bsl-3 to to open release
I mean that it doesn't feel right
somehow so so really thinking about what
does this look like going forward we've
also worked closely with the National
Academies and these two reports are
accessible on the the National Academies
website for free you can download gene
dries on the horizon which which really
sets a path forward that all of our
performers are following of how you can
safely and in a staged manner go after
these technologies and then human genome
editing thinking about if this is
somewhere that we want to go how do we
move forward safely what do we think
about about germline editing and what do
we think about enhancements and so that
brings us to what's next so and should
we really go there so I I like this some
of the work of the the future is scared
where he's made the statement that
humanity change will change more in the
next 20 years than all of recent history
and I do think that we are on a
trajectory towards this on on the
downslope are some of the recent
technologies that are making this
possible on the upslope if you can see
it there's things like human 2.0 human
machine convergence these are these are
things that are somewhere on the horizon
that genome engineering and gene editing
will be a part of so how do we make sure
that we can pursue this this future in a
safe manner one trajectory when possible
trajectory I'll tell you where we are
right now with gene editing and for
humans it's ex vivo cellular
therapeutics so this is taking cells out
of an individual into the laboratory
editing them for some new function
whether it's engineering a t-cell to
attack cancer back in the body but you
can develop and QC all of those reagents
in the laboratory before putting them
back in the individual the next near
future is in vivo therapeutics there's
already FDA approvals to start to
address some of these inherited genetic
diseases from the eyes liver lungs blood
skin GI tract you name it in theory
there should be some solution that's
afforded by genome editing that that
many will start to pursue in each of
these cases this is taking an individual
who is in a diminished unhealthy state
and bringing them back to a baseline
healthy state what do we go beyond that
what's next what about enhancing that
baseline state so there's defensive
enhancement green guy with a shield and
so he this individual we do this already
actually think about vaccination so when
you're vaccinated you actually are
introduced to a change that is lifelong
lasting that protects you from disease
this is an enhancement that that most
individuals are accepting of and even
find it it honorable and a must we
require if our children go to school
that they must be vaccinated there's
other enhancements that would be maybe
offensive enhancements performance
enhancement in cognitive state
do we go there what does that look like
what's the decision-making process to
get us there and then finally an
entirely new baseline state so this is
where Durham line editing comes in and
individuals in the near future we are we
already have demonstrated that it is
possible but you know what how what type
of future does this look like where
there will be edited individuals
unedited individuals who has access to
those technologies and you know this
isn't something that that just happens
on its own this this enhancement is
adaptation occurs through evolution and
I think this is this is a great graphic
from this this paper here where they've
identified genes in humans that where
these are enhancements that make an
individual well adapted to high altitude
or cold temperatures or lactose
metabolism anything that's not
highlighted with a square is our actual
mutations in those genes that increase
the activity but those with the the blue
squares these are these are just gene
dose meaning that if you if you just
increase the level of expression of that
gene you can start to achieve better
lactose metabolism better adaptation to
high altitude we use drugs now to adjust
to many of these types of scenarios but
in the future will there be a question
where we ask you know what what genes
are you on what are what are you
enhanced with who am I talking to and
and you know how do I know where do you
where do you stay in this in this level
of enhancement it's it's you know it's
its evolution really on on steroids now
in our control and so one potential
intermediate solution if we don't want
to go and actually change our genomes is
transient and reversible gene modulation
for humans
so again DNA editing we're taking an
editor cutting the DNA this is a
permanent change we could also modify
the outputs of our genome at the RNA
level so the central dogma and biology
is DNA makes RNA makes protein so can we
interact at the RNA level in a transient
way that once the editor is removed that
that baseline level of expression is
restored there's an incredible paper
last week from a group at the Broad
Institute
that actually is making edits at the RNA
level I work in a military organization
somebody was like everybody's excited
about this paper can you explain it to
me in a way that I can understand and
I'm like okay it's like jumping out of a
plane without your parachute and then
someone intercepts you on the way down
put your parachute on and you can safely
and and it's really it's like you know
here's a gene set loose and you can
correct it along the way so that when it
lands you you have the healthy state of
this of this M gene so this is one way
to transiently modify your genes
activity but then of course for the
aficionados in the room there's CRISPR a
and CRISPR I type approaches where you
have an activator you you eliminate the
ability of a gene editor to actually cut
DNA but it can still go to and find its
place in the genome where it needs to go
and you fuse that to something that is a
transcriptional activated or turn on
gene expression or repress gene
expression you can do so in the
short-term or also make changes that are
long lasting even hundreds of days so
would this be a possible path forward
and if we want to do it you know what
does this look like well we can think
about is in the context of druggable
targets so if we if we take a drug we go
after this gene Network we get our our
desired effects but there's many off
target effects and this is why there's
toxicities and we're sick but if you
have a precision DNA modulator like the
one I've just described you can really
go in and just have your desired effect
without those off target chemically
induced side-effects this might be
something that's that's really an
interesting path to pursue from the
pharmaceutical perspective in the near
term this is already there's literature
starting to accumulate on this topic for
the mitigation of Huntington's disease
this has been done at the modulation
level of the in and at the RNA level for
flu so there's there hasn't been a lot
of new insights to the flu lately except
in in this case a team over expressed
genes that altered the sugar structure
on the surface of cells so that the flu
could no longer invade cells so they
went from about a hundred percent
infection efficiency with influenza down
to I think it was three percent in the
paper this hasn't been done in vivo yet
but you're starting to get so
point where you know maybe I don't want
to knock down expression of receptors on
my cell surface lifelong this could have
damaging effects but if I know I'm going
to be exposed to something it's flu
season I'm getting on a plane maybe you
want to knock that down for the next
four the red-eye flight I have tonight
and then in the future what about entire
G networks we can start to multiplex
several genes at once and knock out or
knock in entire pathways how are we
going to do this so this is something
that I'm technologies I'm interested in
developing inherently they're safer
they're not going to make permanent
modifications to the DNA but first we
need to identify what are those targets
that we're going to modulate if we want
to protect against the next flu or the
next infection where what are those
targets I'm sorry um getting to the
tools to modulate those genes are they
repressors are the activators is it a
multiplex approach and then finally
formulations to deliver those tools if
I'm gonna alter the cellular receptors
on the surface I want to make sure I'm
doing that only in my lungs and not on
my skin or somewhere where it's not
going to be relevant so so those that
the delivery formulation is is really
one of the most challenging aspects of
biology right now getting these tools
where they need to go and we're doing
this in the context where we're talking
with third panel experts and
bioethicists not only the folks at the
National Academies but beyond thinking
about you know okay this is a defensive
enhancement how do we feel about that
how can we have conversations to
understand if this is a place that we
want to go acceptance for genome editing
for somatic therapies and germline
therapies is growing not quite there yet
for Duren line and somatic enhancements
I think this sort of is grouping the
offensive and defensive enhancements
together but really we're solidly on the
defensive side and and just a note about
where this is going so so just last week
the world anti-doping agency banned all
gene editing and sport not really
qualifying what that means but it's
clear you know okay you you could
enhance EPO production there's many
things that that you could do to enhance
physical performance and you know how
are they going to monitor this if you
if you're increasing the dosage of a
gene I just I don't know if they'll be
looking for the tool or or what in these
contacts I'll be curious to follow where
that's going and just to close out we
started with the ARPANET and well it
will end with a quote from Licklider who
was the program manager under the
ARPANET he had this vision at the
beginning understanding the impact that
the ARPANET will have and he said to
will to be online be a privilege or a
right and it's important to think about
genome editing technologies as as we
change our world going forward we don't
want it to be a situation where there
will be a select few that have access to
these technologies how do we push the
conversation out to the the greatest
group possible to weigh in on where we
want to go with that I thank you very
much for your attention
[Applause]
all right deep breath I talk really fast
sorry say a little bit about I Jim we
had a talk maybe two years ago from Drew
endy about the sort of IgM revolution
and you've been involved in that as a
judge I think see what IgM is and how
you think it relates to what you've been
talking about so idem is the
International genetically engineered
machines competition
I think it's been around for about 10
years now if I'm if I'm not mistaken and
give her more than that and the idea is
is it's a summer lab project for
students at the undergraduate graduate
level universities to have an idea about
synthetic biology and make it a reality
over this short period of time they have
access to what are called BioBricks
these are the the building blocks the
genes that can be used to sort of start
their designs but they can build upon
these designs but I think one of the
things I really like about idem is there
two things actually so so one is each
and every project has a what's called
human practices and so this is thinking
about safety in the context of those
projects so the team comes together at
the beginning how they're approaching
what they do that's right yep they they
they put out a plan to how they're going
to address safety in these contexts and
they they also engage with their local
communities and that's part of the
entire project and they get scored on
that interestingly
eye gems sometimes the safety
requirements of the iGEM competition are
more stringent than the requirements of
the countries where the individuals are
coming from to compete where do they
come from all over the world I I don't I
I think that if there's a country you
name it they're participating in I Jim
and so that's actually I think been a
great way to establish norms in
synthetic biology and how those students
take them back to their to their home
countries the way to do that is a
question information
can you describe the international
conversation gene-editing safety so IBM
is clearly part of that what sort of the
graduate and postgraduate versions so I
was actually just two weeks ago in
Germany the Volkswagen stiff doing funds
conversations about many topics
including genome editing and security
implications so there was
representatives from the department
defense from the State Department and
elsewhere within from the United States
but from countries all over the world
they brought students and individuals
together to talk about gene editing and
what that means and it was actually a
really interesting conversation I think
it was the first conversation to get to
know each other and get comfortable with
with how we think about these
technologies so so some countries are
pretty bullish using these technologies
GMOs are a great example right the US
and then Europe is not and although I
did visit a research lab in Europe that
was developing GMOs for other countries
outside of Europe so and it's an
interesting point and I sort of boggle
my mind I'm like how could you be
developing GMO plants and you don't use
them Europe and and this person who
relate this to me said we didn't have
the conversation with the public at the
time for developing the GMOs so the the
research was in in in Germany and
elsewhere in Europe were pursuing these
technologies but but those in the the
public didn't have a say and so so
there's a dichotomy there now so how
does the public have a say angle on this
and one of the people you're funding is
Kim and I spelled I think whose hard
over for basically you're asking public
permission before you can do the
research and things like that what's
your perspective on that level of
transparency and permission seeking so
from the safe teens perspective I where
we want to be as transparent as possible
where we've provided funding for each of
our teams to make sure that they can
have those conversations publicly who
want them to publish other research
we're requiring them to share their data
you know I I do think that we
that transparency there's a
responsibility to be there to translate
the information that you provide to the
public so just a data dump of sequence
on the public isn't gonna do much good
but you know being able to to confer
with them and say this is what this
information means and why it's important
and be there to answer questions I think
is going to be critical well surely
there's some kind of a lag or something
here I mean it's taken a while for
people to get sort of you know they went
through the bits and bytes level of
understanding what programming digitally
is about and genetics are way more
complex and strange
personal then you know some nice safe
machine across the room is there a and
it sounds like the young the many young
teams that are involved in IgM are sort
of one way of them engaging this as
practitioners not just as somebody
hearing about it and worrying about it
but there are a lot of people hearing
about it and worrying about it and for
whom genetics has a past of the bad seed
and these various things that we worry
about genetics couldn't be just a lack
of people saying look it's genetics and
I don't understand it therefore don't do
it and or and then how do you overcome
that because the understanding itself is
difficult how deep you have to go do you
really have to understand the mechanism
of a CRISPR cast 9 right which you know
I promote avidly and I am frankly I
could not explain it right so you know I
I don't have a perfect answer to your
question but it but I do think it is
important to engage the communities and
I try to not be at that we just have to
educate them more so they understand and
and you know I don't think that's that's
really it's it's listening in both
directions and so so we have a gentleman
Jason Dell born so he's he's from NCSU
funded under safe Jean so I'm just going
to do with Delma what he does I give me
your hands Stewart so so we're engaging
now and part of this engagement means
that we can sway each other so
you may have an opinion I have an
opinion but we're both movable in this
conversation and I love that
demonstration that Jason has because if
you're going to engage with the public
do it in a way that's meaningful that
you're both vulnerable and that there is
some movement there you may not
completely understand each other where
you're coming from but but you're open
to to that movement
outstanding Kevin Kelly back on the
International a so they're similar
programs to DARPA in China and Asia and
Europe or are you guys unique Cydia
they're similar programs to DARPA
elsewhere like you know I just saw news
clips that that I was so embarrassed and
forgetting the name of the leader in
France marine lepen so there was there
was some France just recently I
apologize for not knowing the name has
has stated we we should get something
like an ARPA or a DARPA agency so there
are others I think that are that are
looking at DARPA as a model
there's certainly companies that are
that are thinking about this but
specific names I I think you know there
are sort of counterparts in the UK we
have the STL is an organization there
that that sort of models some of their
work on on DARPA but there's not there's
not a you know identical clones
somewhere elsewhere in the world
DARPA itself is a very American national
government organization do you guys sort
of have your own outreach to other
countries how does that work we do we
have delegates from other companies
these countries come and visit DARPA to
learn about the organization and what we
do we sometimes do that at the office
level so I'm in the biological
technologies office so so we've engaged
with with counterparts in the UK and
Japan recently are some examples I can
think of and other other offices do so
as well but of course we are a National
Security Agency but you know we have
allies across the world that we work
with yeah I was just with Ryan in
Australia at see cyber overtures
government research organization they
got some money that you just now put yep
so they're looking at some of the
environmental assessment and risk
assessment for for the technologies
CSIRO so this is with a mammalian gene
drives we also fund groups from the UK
on some of the mosquito work so so a
group at Imperial College and a group in
the purebred Institute
I heard the amount that's going to this
current sort of trauma researchers sixty
five million okay more coming later or
how does that work no well not from
DARPA so the the key of DARPA is we we
make that early investment to show
demonstrate that something is actually
possible and early on we try to line up
those advanced developers who can pick
up our technologies whether they're a
company or another government entity to
develop that further couple questions
here relating to basically digital
questions sig knew looks like I says
speaking of designing a safety at the
beginning Eric Schmidt gave an interview
where he said if they thought about
safety at the early stages of the
internet it would never have been
developed so is safety potentially a
strangling thing that happens I
personally don't don't think so an
analogy that that I like to use is if
you if you think about your car you know
you don't have your brakes in your car
so so you can go slow you have the
brakes so you can go very fast get where
you need to go but it's an when you
should need to stop you have the power
to do so and I think we need that
personally for for gene editing and I do
see this as a way to accelerate bringing
these technologies to market I think
imagine if it's done in a way which
people really get it it also accelerates
the sort of public permission or social
license to proceed with these things
people have some confidence that is
moving ahead safely we'll see we've
learned from biological systems too if
we build a system and optimize it and
and try to retrofit safety into that
system it breaks the system and so it's
really critical to have safety as a
design feature early on there's there's
a great paper by by Jim Collins where he
developed these kill switches so he and
ecoli that's dividing added a kill
switch it'll kill the bacteria really
for the first generation or two it works
great but if you monitor those systems
over many days evolution kind of you
know there's no greater greater pressure
you can put on it evolutionary on a
system then to kill it right so it's
gonna try to evolve around that and so
if but if we can build that in from the
beginning would those systems look
differently I I don't know but we're
trying to establish that as part of safe
teens another digital related question
from Chris either a or H can you speak
to the efforts of any to combine
artificial intelligence machine learning
and so on with gene editing is that
something which is enhancing analysis so
part of what I'm interested in in
pursuing in in future efforts would be
looking at if we want to identify gene
targets that we can potentially modulate
there could be some information that we
learn in terms of of targeting those
genes that AI could be supportive and in
the living foundries project that I
mentioned me we do apply AI there
through several of our teams to to
search the genetics face sequence space
that's out there to look for new enzymes
that can catalyze reactions to create
new molecules that are that are of
interest so it's applied today I'm not
not sure the exact application that that
you mean here so I think it's coming
together it's not quite there yet but
but I that will I think be an increasing
part of it going forward the whole
genetic universe is such a sort of data
vast domain that one command would like
every possible help you could get to be
able to identify things I think thinking
about human gene editing too when we
think about AI so full disclosure I'm
not an AI expert so what I say right now
may not be right but what I understand
is there's there's sort
you ask the system a question a little
bit of a black box you get an answer out
at the back end and it's a probabilistic
answer but but how it is how the AI
system reaches that answer we're not
quite sure of and DARPA now is trying to
we have a program called explainable AI
to say okay if we get to an answer
winnable explainable AI so how do we get
to that answer and most importantly when
the answer is wrong how do we figure out
how the system got it wrong and if you
think about that context for gene
editing if we want to use these tools AI
tools to identify targets for disease if
we get something wrong and it causes
maybe a worse state than the original
disease that we're trying to correct we
want to be able to go back in that
system and understand you know what what
did we do wrong when we when we allowed
the AI to design that system explainable
yeah is pretty interesting because one
of the things that's been emerging from
some of these just sort of learning from
the system systems that are out there is
that they develop algorithms that are so
hidden in the code we don't know what
they are and this is you're trying to
make it so that we can know what they
are right exactly
I'm not something else is well that
raises it so how many program managers
are at DARPA right now it's a pretty
lean organization there's about a
hundred of us however so uh and do you
characters interrelate with each other
so if you have a potential you know
application of a others they're an AFO
Graham manager you would say would you
look at this situation and help me out
or how does that work absolutely so you
know we as everybody is we're we have a
full day but we always try to talk with
people on other floors the way doctors
organized at each floor is kind of a
technical office and so I do talk with
folks in the I to office so information
innovation office about using the tools
of AI and even just a data Commons for
the safety is community this is where
they're gonna be putting their data not
only to share across among the the safe
teens teams but to have other people
working as modelers in areas that maybe
have nothing to do with biology to look
at the data set and say are there things
that we can learn from the data that's
being accumulated over over many
generations
you know that there may be some unique
insight so so I think a lot of the
really exciting innovation at DARPA
comes when multiple disciplines come
together and do great things that stuff
Clayton asks what is crispers potential
role in the development of full
appreciation of biological weapons and
it's already too late our national
security
DARPA Defense Advanced Research Projects
Agency presumably the worry about bio
weapons is got to be in there is CRISPR
a potential significant tool for bio
weapons so it is another tool in the
toolkit certainly I gave you the example
of the horse pox virus so so there's a
real tangible example of some of these
tools not specifically CRISPR in that
case but new genome tools making those
possible so I think that yes it's it
will play a role it's going to be you
know pushing these technologies out I
hate to speculate I always get really
uncomfortable speculating I don't want
to speculate but you know I think this
is a place where you can look to science
fiction and and some of the the books
that have been actually but I'm
published recently on the topic come
forward with really frightening scenario
is about where you could do things like
I could commit a crime but I could use
CRISPR to put my my CODIS my STR you
know what the FBI uses it's just kind of
snips it to say okay here's here's these
repeats that are unique to Renee I can
CRISPR those on to you so now you're
responsible for the crime Stuart and you
know I don't know how near-term that is
but these are some of the the
fantastical scenarios that you know may
become a reality so part of this must be
monitoring genes are very small and
they're hidden in a very thick bush of
other things which are genes and not
genes and so on
so somebody deployed a thing that one
might consider a director indirect by a
weapon or one of the things that you
care about did get in a sense loose in a
way that was not intended
supposed to be supplementing units not
self-limiting are their genetic level
ways to detect that kind of problem
mm-hmm um you know I don't think those
exist right now so you could monitor for
the tool for the actual editor itself
but that's probably going to be
short-lived so it's if it's going to
introduce an edit into your genome it'll
be there until it turns over that
substrate and then it'll be gone so you
have to catch it in that window of
opportunity there's another ARPA agency
so I ARPA that's developing a program
specifically to look at can you monitor
and look for signatures of engineering
whether it's crisper
casts or or you know whatever the next
editor coming down the pipeline is can
we look at a sequence and know if it's
been manipulated but those those don't
exist today it's like the ones that are
looking at photographs to tell if
they've been emulated and things like
that absolutely I are opposed
intelligence organizing of course this
question there will always be a version
of Bob kopeck that looks like says how
long before some high school student
creates a unicorn that's the science
fair project oh that's awesome I'm sure
that my daughter wants to probably well
I don't we're doing the reverse oh so I
know companies are developing hornless
cattle now so so maybe we they need to
reverse engineer or just one of the ones
you know why wrong was cattle right and
this is something we're evoking at
revive and restore because I'll say a
little about it
cattle hurt each other with their horns
and so people who are caring for cattle
dehorn them and it's painful for them
there's a theory as well and I'm a
welfare issue here and so it turns out
there's a relatively simple gene edit to
which already occurs in some cattle they
don't have horns use that and other
cattle now they don't have horns and
they don't hurt each other that's what
the horn was cattle thing that's coming
on it's it looks good the cows a little
strange welfare people should be
cheering and I hope our but it's the
kind of thing that we're seeing going up
animal welfare so so DARPA just recently
got a letter from PETA commending us
believe it or not on a program called
the micro physiological systems program
so MPs this is it's essentially an on a
chip program so it organs on a chip to
recapitulate what an animal model might
look like and and behave like so you can
you can do all the experimentation on
that chip and not actually have to
sacrifice an animal so so PETA sent us a
letter of commendation on that program P
this interesting LP to come out it came
out strong in terms of basically grown
back ground meat and impossible burgers
and things like that and I agree I think
anything that is reducing animal
suffering and is reducing animal
agriculture impact than the landscape is
a good thing waiting to ask what
unexpected risks have developed and your
current projects and generally not just
unexpected risk but what are the
surprises so far as research so you're
supposed to be surprised what's turned
up so it's something that's happened in
in my projects over the past two years
is I used to hear from individuals you
know so we're
progress and they'll say well we're
cloning this right now so we're busy in
the lab making this happen and that's
changed too well we're waiting for the
DNA to arrive so nobody closed anything
anymore and that's I've been surprised
at how quickly this has has become the
the reality everybody orders their their
DNA from from a third party you know
these these simplistic BioBricks were
for microbes that I Jim was doing is
it's gone beyond that it sounds like
great yes so you know people can for the
living foundries program is a great
example so we challenge the teams to
create molecules of interest sometimes
they have to stitch together mm-hmm
maybe 1020 enzymes to to catalyze a
reaction across these multiple steps and
so they'll order each of those genes
from a DNA synthesis company and then
they can assemble those in in-house into
these these long stretches of DNA and
they don't really need to do the cloning
as they they used to do manually you
know amplify pieces of DNA stitch them
together they can they can just order
those pieces now so that so from a
funders perspective I do find it to be
one of the most expensive components on
our projects is that what in the grand
scheme of things yeah the cost really is
going down you mentioned molecules of
interest
okay so sorry so from from the the DoD
perspective these can be anything from a
small molecule a drug to adhesive a
coating new materials epoxies hardeners
really you name it and we want to be
able to access that that chemical space
so as a as a country actually not not
just the DoD you know there's many
things that we source either that are
very costly because we may extract them
from biological systems or we have to
source them internationally they're not
available in the United States and so
how do we bring those capabilities here
that are cost-effective and and produced
domestically I think there's a lot of
signage and people in the house here if
I'm not mistaken doing this as part of
of that project and I'll say of the
thousand molecules you want them the
three teams collectively to produce
they've made 551 so it's working
and what makes them a bit so they're not
randomly making molecules they're making
molecules that are somewhat targeted or
somewhat adjustments you already know in
molecules or what so so there's there's
three limits to get that specific about
how the contracts were set up there's
three levels some are the first level of
molecule are things that have been made
by biology already but making them them
better and more cost-effective so those
are you see the low-hanging fruit
there's a pathway there they know they
know how to do it in Syria but make it
better the second category are things
that there there are enzymes that exist
in nature that should theoretically be
possible to make but they need to be
stitched together into a single organism
to do that and then there's the third
category which are just things that have
never been made by biology before and so
these are these are very challenging to
engineer this is we've had a one
performer recently our grantees we call
performers say I've run out of cross
database performer or go away
but but yes so they look at really
metagenomics you know enzymes from from
the you know from deep thermal events in
the ocean to high peaks to look at the
enzymes that are present in these
organisms to stitch them together to
catalyze reactions okay question on
George church's program which I hadn't
realized into the mention of basically
being able to correct radiological
damage people since the major human
impact of travel in the space is the
exposure to cosmic rays which shorten
everybody's life basically by doing a
lot of DNA damage from the radiation
there's one potential product of this if
it works
people that have comfortable traveling
in space without a whole lot of
cladding mm-hmm so I you know I don't
think that any of these technologies
would would replace shielding or
protective equipment that would be
required for a long-term space travel
mission but we you know your your point
is well-taken that we're we're we're
pushing to to travel to Mars or the moon
or elsewhere and I don't think we're
keeping pace with the development of
those you know the hardware and
technology we're not keeping pace with
the development of you know really
protections for the human element that
will be there are there ways that we can
protect those future space travelers
from radiation damage reverse that
radiation damage protect from would be
really nice I raise the question with
you earlier which is one of the things
going on as you may know and climate
change in geoengineering is the desire
to be able to capture carbon from the
atmosphere carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere and fix it in a way that it
doesn't keep cycling back and there are
some organisms in the oceans which do
that if I complain to do it for example
they don't do it as much as we would
like in order to gather you know back
down below 400 parts per million so one
could imagine engineering microbes which
are comfortable in the ocean and
collaborate widely that are extra
special good at basically collecting
carbon dioxide probably put in some kind
of shell or something examine the
organism dies shell goes to the bottom
and is geologically going for a long
time is that doable is that okay
so so you know my I don't know I'd love
to see a you know a project plan that
looks at that but if we think about it
so number five was Ohio Meyer catechism
what are the risks you know what one of
the things would be what if what is that
system you just described continues in
an uncontrolled way so that we not only
fix carbon but then we start to
sequester carbon we move into the next
ice age you know there in the oceans out
there if you build in safety from the
beginning so if you how would you build
in for a system like that what you're
basically releasing into the wild know
most of these things we're talking about
our ecosystem level like rodents in the
wild like Lyme disease carrying quite
footed mice in the wild and so on what
are ways to localize and potentially
reverse say gene Drive applications of
getting deleterious genes in the case of
animals you're trying to reduce or
extinct what are the methods now of
modulating that so I don't know that
they exist yet we're trying to establish
those in part under the the safe teens
you know it really that the best
solutions I've seen so far are reversal
Drive so so if you if you drive and
train that because you know what's up
you only get to talk up again right
right exactly so I you know they're I
don't know what what can keep keep pace
with that and I you know welcome with
some concepts of how we can address that
but well you mentioned generation
counting the thing might sort of only
apply for so many generations and then
it either stops or prints out or
something
sure so so some of those are self
eliminating where you can you can use a
genetic trick to flip a gene every
through every cycle of reproduction that
it promoter is turned on and the
germline it flips the gene and you can
insert any number of flips there you can
put
ten flips and that would be a ten
generation counter for example so it's
it's it's a physical and permanent
change in that in that genome to
maintain that state this is one way you
can do it you could also have those
systems become self-extracting where you
can have there's there's a multitude of
gene editors there's there's there's
castes there's CPS CPF and you can have
one target the other to self eliminate
would be another example she's been at
this how long now and almost two years
what do you learned so far
Kevin Kelley puts the question and what
have you changed your mind about
recently after working on this what if I
what does my changed my mind about
working on this you know I I definitely
feel more confident that I was like if
anybody gonna think this is a good idea
and the more I learn about the impacts
that these technologies are having a
little bit I think I heard that you sort
of went in with this proposal and
usually program managers they have two
or three proposals before they're taken
seriously you were getting seriously
right away well I'd been around a little
while so I sort of knew the the DARPA
way of thinking hmm and it was you know
genuinely I really wanted to sound
cheesy but I wanted to serve my country
in this way I never served that's not
cheesy but I really felt you know this
is something that I wanted to do I was I
was excited at the innovation coming out
of the United States and I wanted to to
protect that so that we could pursue
these technologies so I was I was you
know maybe one of the pleasant surprises
is is you know there's actually a lot of
other people that don't want these
technologies to move forward safely and
maybe that's that's not surprising as it
should be and you know I I think I've
been surprised at finding common ground
in conversations about conservation for
example where maybe I hadn't
and you know cosmic exploration there's
there's insights from new fields that
you know I've learned about over the the
years that have just been really yeah
I'm leaving myself open to those
conversations and you know hope to
continue to do so so as an individual
I've learned that you know having those
open conversations has really been
valuable to me thank you for the open
conversation today is going to keep
expanding
[Applause]
[Music]